someone has been struggled with that a
chaotic scene inside of Congressman
Jerry Connolly Suburban Virginia office
after police say a 49 year old man went
on a rampage Monday a jacking two
staffers including an intern with a
metal baseball bat we had a young intern
her first day on the job at the
reception desk and she told us I wasn't
there he then proceeded to beat her with
the bat the suspect Juan Kar trammed fam
is charged with two counts including
aggravated malicious wounding
police are also investigating an earlier
alleged incident where he seen chasing a
woman with a bat before going to
Connolly's office the suspect's father
told the Washington Post that his son
has suffered from schizophrenia since he
was a teen the incident comes after a
string of recent violent attacks
involving lawmakers